well done for those of you who had a
whirl through this question
um i went to a couple of breakout rooms
where i found some people who
absolutely knew what they were doing
which is great i didn't encounter anyone
yet anyway
who had more than one solution um or one
method uh more than one method
can you post in the chat by the way i'm
just curious just go ahead and say yeah
we got two methods or we've got three or
whatever
um did anyone get more than one or if
not just write one
or you can write zero if you like you're
like i have nowhere to go
okay so xiao's got a couple that's good
didn't anyone else
i'd love to hear uh get a bit of
feedback before i show you my
um i've got i i have light chao i've got
two methods that i'm going to show you
we've got one and a half if you if you
got one
and then you have like another path even
if you didn't finish it i gave you a
criminally short amount of time
so i'm okay with that okay all right no
problem well look
um i'm on the clock so just before i
start this just so it doesn't get lost
at the end of this
can i encourage all of you um to use
these questions what's really nice about
them is a bunch of them have work
solutions
um which is great they're not always the
most easy to interpret sometimes i look
at them and i'm like how did you do
that's there
but you're welcome to ask and we'd like
you guys to do that for all the topics
and post any questions to us so that we
can
incorporate them into your revision
lessons let's have a go shall we
prove that for any integer n is greater
than one
the log base n of n plus one is
irrational and they're going to throw
three marks at us for this apparently
and it's just from last year's hsc now
the first thing you've got to decide is
uh unlike the previous question where
it's like oh it's an
inequality there's algebra i'm just
gonna throw some algebraic manipulation
at it right
in this case you've gotta be a little
more thoughtful before you can even put
pen to paper
you have to decide on a way to go about
this that's gonna give you a useful path
to it
and i'm going to suggest to you and i'm
going to pause for a minute just to give
you guys a moment to think about it
i'm going to suggest to you that this is
a classic example of where proof by
contradiction
is going to be uh probably the most easy
way to prove this even though it is so
indirect like the whole point of proving
by contradiction is indirect
now what is the big clue i'm just
pausing for a minute to give you guys
before i go through the proof
an opportunity to recognize if you
didn't get this that this would be
helpful right
what's the clue in the question that
sort of suggests to you that proving
this by contradiction might be useful
and for me um there's just a single word
right and admittedly you don't have that
many words to choose from
um and especially when you're realizing
what like what makes this question
unusual as compared to other questions
it's this final word within the sentence
which is
irrational right what does irrational
mean it means you cannot express this
number as a ratio
of two integers that's what it means to
be irrational we have
loads of numbers like that um square
roots of any numbers that aren't squares
um you know the transcendental numbers
like pi and e those good those good guys
um and um you know a bunch of the logs
are
irrational right so we're going to try
and prove that
log base 2 of 3 or log base 100 of 101
they're all rational how we can do it
and the answer is we're going to try and
say
that it is rational and then arrive at a
contradiction because that's much easier
to actually say
that something is true rather than
something is like the word irrational
has a negation within it already right
and negations can be quite tricky to
work with
so here's how we start a proof by
contradiction
has to assume that the statement that
we're asked to prove
is false we're going to assume the
negation
and you have to be quite careful about
how you state this right so i'm going to
assume that i can say
this log term here as p over q
classic kind of choice of prone rules
here p and q have to be integers
and this is important too if you've
never hopefully you've seen this word i
know i've talked about it a couple times
here and there in some my videos
co prime means it doesn't share any the
p and q don't share any common factors
right
so they are prime sort of to each other
even if p and q
aren't necessarily prime so 10 and 3 are
co-prime
even though 10's not prime because 10
and 3 don't share any factors
all right so now that i've set that up
what am i going to do with it well what
i'm going to
try and find out is a contradiction out
of this result so i just start to
manipulate this right
so this is a log statement and i've just
turned it into an exponential one
and then from there i notice that i can
raise both
sides left and right to the power of q
and i get this statement right here
okay now why is this a useful statement
remember what i'm trying to do is get to
something which doesn't make sense
something which is contradictory and
this is an equation
which cannot possibly be true and i just
have to prove
why it can't be true right remember n
is not just any number it is an integer
up here and it's an integer greater than
one so
what that means is you've got whole
numbers going into here and then you're
raising them
to whole numbers right now if it's not
obvious to you
try some numbers it's always um helpful
especially when you've got so much um
algebra so many pronumerals lying around
to try some numbers right so if i said
like
what if n was say 2 okay i'd have 2 to
the n
or sorry 2 to the p rather equals and
then on the right hand side
n plus 1 is going to be 3 and then
that's the power of q
now hopefully you can see here like you
might know the powers of two right
um 2 4 8 16 32 64
and so on right because of the way
you're building that number you're never
going to have a
factor of 3. the powers of three are
three
nine twenty seven eighty one uh
my brain is already two hundred forty
three we're gonna sort of struggle from
there
um they're all odd right and the powers
of two are all even
and if i chose some other numbers like
say
you know if i chose four then this would
be
five you're gonna have the same problem
right powers of four
four sixteen sixty four two fifty six
and then powers of five
5 25 125 625
you're getting all evens on the left
hand side and all
odds on the right and you have to
because if n is even
then n plus 1 is odd and the reverse is
also true
so what i need to do is go from just
this these numerical examples to how do
i prove that
how i state it so it's generally true so
here's the way i've laid this out
i've said let's do this by cases you
might also hear this called proof by
exhaustion we're going to exhaust every
possible way that this could be
um laid out so if n is odd you raise it
to any integer power
and you'll get another odd number right
but if n is odd then n plus 1
is even we saw that with 2 and uh sorry
i i actually did the other way around i
started with n being even and go the
other way
but if you've got n plus one being even
then once you raise it to an integer
power that's
also even i should say a positive
integer power
and so therefore i can say well i've got
a contradiction right that the left hand
side is odd
the right hand side is even so that's
something which can't be true
and then you can reverse that right you
can say well what happens if it's even
on the left
and then odd on the right that is also a
contradiction
so therefore um it's a bit notation
heavy but hopefully you can read this
with me
n to the power of p cannot possibly be
equal to
n plus 1 to the power of q for every
value for all the values of n
that are integers um and so since that
can't work right we've landed on these
contradictions
that original assumption which set this
all in motion has to be false
therefore it's not rational it's
irrational